[Música]
son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día a ustedes
Les agradecemos su sintonía vamos con
los titulares de esta jornada
el Secretario de Defensa de Estados
Unidos
aseguró que buscarán hasta debajo de las
piedras al responsable de la reciente
filtración de documentos de pentágono el
funcionario añadió que Washington
continúa trabajando de cerca con sus
socios Pese a que los archivos
presuntamente revelan que la
administración habría espiado a países
aliados
Colombia Panamá y Estados Unidos
acordaron una campaña de dos meses de
duración para enfrentar la migración
irregular a través del llamado tapón del
Darién la selva que ocupa la zona
fronteriza entre Colombia y Panamá la
iniciativa Busca acabar con el tránsito
ilícito de personas y de bienes
en Chile el presidente Gabriel borics
celebró la decisión Del parlamento que
aprobó reducir la jornada laboral de 45
de 40 y de 45 40 horas el jefe de estado
la calificó de indispensable para un
chile más justo la normativa se
implementará gradualmente hasta llegar a
la meta en cinco años ampliamos desde
Santiago
[Música]
[Aplausos]
nosotros comenzamos en Estados Unidos
donde el gobierno continúa tratando de
paliar El impacto de las filtraciones de
documentos del pentágono en las que hay
todo tipo de información estratégica
militar y diplomática que evidencia
posturas de Washington sobre la guerra
en Ucrania en relación con aliados como
Israel y Corea del Sur o seguimientos a
países como Egipto y Rusia el Secretario
de Defensa aseguró que investigaran el
hecho para identificar a los
responsables para analizar el impacto
que tiene esto a nivel internacional
está con nosotros Héctor Torres Pérez él
es profesor catedrático exoficial de
inteligencia Y fuerzas especiales del
ejército de Estados Unidos Bienvenido a
France 24 no es nuevo que Washington
espía o haga seguimiento a sus aliados o
enemigos pero en el contexto actual Qué
tan grave puede ser dar a conocer tanta
información estratégica a nivel militar
e información de relaciones con otros
países
definitivamente es preocupante para la
nación americana que haya salido tanta
información
no solo de todas las operaciones de
inteligencia ni quién a quién estamos
tratando de
de examinar sino que sale también mucha
información que tiene que ver con
nuestros aliados
y no es la Perdón disculpame
qué tendrá que hacer Estados Unidos para
reparar las relaciones justamente con
sus aliados que se han visto afectadas
por la filtración esto Podría tener
efectos a largo plazo
sí siempre hay efectos a largo plazo
aquí lo que hay que hacer es una
investigación
concienzuda comprensiva y ver cómo esto
se eligió a los medios
esto salió
preliminarmente ya sabemos que esto
salió del Estado Mayor conjunto que hay
en el pentágono de la oficina
específicamente del j2 de la oficina de
inteligencia donde todo se deposita y
Aparentemente lo que
estoy analizando es que posiblemente hay
una persona
no muy contenta que decidió vengarse
y decidió sacar a flote toda esta
información
Bueno y quién se beneficia con este tipo
de filtración por ejemplo Rusia podría
tomar como fiable estos datos publicados
Y aprovecharlos en la guerra
yo se puede pensar que esto es una
manipulación y que la información que
está saliendo afuera es es falsa
o puede esa información y
manipularlos ellos Acuérdate que ellos
son ellos tienen un programa que se
conoce como desinformación en un
programa estratégico que ellos cogen una
noticia y la vieran patas arriba para
tratar de
de manipular
a la gente a la masa como un intento de
operaciones psicológicas
estratégicas Así que ellos ahora están
tratando Yo sé que Rusia ahora mismo
debe estar tratando de averiguar cuán
cierta es esta información a través de
otros medios que lo puedan comprobar y
si no Y si es cierta pues entonces
tratar de utilizarla para manipularla en
el contexto de de una operación de
operaciones psicológicas pues señor
Torres a usted muchas gracias por su
análisis y por compartirlo con nosotros
en France 24
encantado Gracias Valentina nosotros
cambiamos de tema porque reunidos en
Ciudad de Panamá el secretario de
seguridad Nacional de Estados Unidos y
los cancilleres de Panamá y Colombia
acordaron un plan de dos meses para
enfrentar la migración irregular en la
selva del Darién que conecta a Panamá y
Colombia la campaña Busca acabar con el
movimiento ilícito de personas y de
bienes por vía terrestre o marítima en
una de las regiones más afectadas por
los flujos migratorios irregulares con
más de 87,000 cruces solo en lo que va
de 2023
Panamá Colombia y Estados Unidos se
enfocarán en tres líneas de esfuerzo
terminar con el movimiento ilícito de
bienes y personas a través del Darién y
el corredor marítimo que lleva a la
muerte y explotación de personas
vulnerables por ganancias significativas
abrir nuevos caminos legales para
decenas de miles de migrantes y
refugiados como una alternativa a la
migración irregular y tercero lanzar un
plan para reducir la pobreza y crear
empleos en comunidades fronterizas del
norte de Colombia y sur de Panamá para
asociarse con organismos internacionales
instituciones financieras y el sector
privado
al menos nueve personas perdieron la
vida en medio de un tiroteo registrado
en el norte de Ecuador los hechos
ocurrieron en un puerto pesquero de
esmeraldas capital de la provincia
ecuatoriana del mismo nombre fronteriza
con Colombia cuando un grupo armado
abrió Fuego contra Pescadores que
trabajan en la zona Gustavo Ortega
corresponsal de France 24 en Quito nos
amplió los detalles
un ataque de 20 personas fuertemente
armadas al estilo sicariato se produjo
en el puerto pesquero artesanal de la
provincia costera de esmeraldas según el
informe policial la lucha de territorio
y enfrentamientos entre grupos de
delincuencia organizada son los motivos
de los ataques producidos en Ecuador
recientemente en medio de una gran
crisis de inseguridad que vive el país
el ataque se produjo con armas cortas y
armas largas según informó el titular y
Justicia ecuatoriano Juan Zapata quien
confirmó que en el lugar existe más de
200 indicios balísticos registrados en
el lugar del suceso la Policía Nacional
y las fuerzas armadas desarrollan
operativo y se han confirmado 60
allanamientos hasta el momento para
capturar hacia los responsables sucedió
cuando los atacantes llegaron por mar y
por tierra y dispararon
indiscriminadamente cuando se
encontraban 2000 personas en el sector
entre pesqueros y comerciantes según
informaron las autoridades el ministro
de interior y Justicia confirmó que los
ataques son consecuencias de operativos
en contra el narcotráfico y el crimen
organizado que intenta cambiar a la
modalidad de las vacunas a comerciantes
la provincia de Esmeralda tuvo un estado
de sección desde el 3 de marzo hasta el
10 de Abril donde se decomisaron solo en
esta provincia 1403 kilogramos de droga
y se desarticularon a cinco grupos
organizados los trabajadores que se
encontraban en el lugar se lanzaron al
mar para intentar sobrevivir al ataque
armado la provincia de esmeraldas maneja
la tasa de muertes más violentas del
país con un promedio de 16 asesinatos
por día el presidente de Brasil Luis
Ignacio Lula da Silva inició su viaje a
China que había sido postergado por
problemas de salud se trata de una
visita de estado con la que ambos
naciones aliadas bajo el marco de Los
bricks pretenden estrechar lazos
comerciales
en un reinicio de las relaciones entre
Brasil y China después de cuatro años de
relativo aislamiento internacional con
el expresidente Jair bolsonaro el
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
tiene un objetivo claro fortalecer el
vínculo ya profundo entre Brasilia y
Beijing China es el principal socio
comercial de y un importante mercado
para la soja el mineral de hierro y el
petróleo brasiles también el mayor
receptor de inversión china en América
Latina durante su visita de estado el
presidente Lula también tiene un segundo
objetivo reactivar la alianza brix una
agrupación de las principales economías
de Mercado emergentes del mundo
compuesta por Brasil Rusia India China y
Sudáfrica una idea que Beijing parece
ver con buenos ojos
china está dispuesta a trabajar con
Brasil para utilizar Esta visita como
una oportunidad para promover una
cooperación mutuamente beneficiosa y
amistosa entre los países en desarrollo
y para abordar juntos los desafíos
globales
se espera también que Lula asista a la
toma de posesión de la expresidenta
Dilma hussef como directora del banco de
desarrollo brix el cual Busca la
creación de una moneda común que permita
a los socios comerciales evitar el uso
del dólar a finales de marzo China y
Brasil anunciaron un acuerdo para
comerciar entre sí sus monedas
nacionales Lula tenía previsto viajar a
Beijing en ese momento pero lo pospuso
debido a una enfermedad sin embargo
envió parte de su delegación compuesta
por representantes del gobierno y
empresas privadas Allí se concluyeron
más de 20 acuerdos comerciales en varios
sectores
también sobre la mesa que Brasil se una
a la iniciativa de la nueva ruta de la
seda un gigantesco proyecto de inversión
china que a Beijing le gustaría extender
aún más en América del Sur
la cámara de diputados de chile aprobó
una ley que reduce de 45 a 40 las horas
laborales por semana ese país en ese
país suramericano se ha tratado de un
proyecto que había sido presentado
inicialmente en 2017 pero que enfrentó
muchas complicaciones hasta que fue
retomado por el presidente Gabriel la
normativa ahora espera la promulgación
del mandatario Patricia Luna
corresponsal de France 24 en Chile nos
informa desde Santiago
el congreso chileno aprobó Este martes
por amplia mayoría la ley que reduce la
jornada laboral para los chilenos de 45
horas actuales a 40 horas semanales fue
en la cámara de diputados donde 127
diputados votaron a favor 14 lo hicieron
en contra y hubo tres abstenciones el
último trámite legislativo de una ley
que tardó 6 años en pasar por el
congreso y que tardará cinco en
implementarse puesto que contempla una
implementación paulatina se reducirá en
el primer año de supuesta en marcha de
45 a 44 horas semanales pasará a 42 en
el plazo de dos años siguientes y de ahí
a las 40 horas en un plazo de cinco años
sin embargo según adelantó la ministra
de trabajo Janet Jara cuya labor fue
incansable para conseguir que la ley
saliera adelante dependerá de los
acuerdos particulares entre las empresas
y sus empleadores que la implementación
de la ley pueda agilizarse y ponerse en
marcha antes de esos cinco años que
establece la normativa también en
algunos casos concretos se podría
valorar la posibilidad de que hubiera
cuatro días de trabajo y tres de
descanso fue una jornada muy emotiva en
el congreso donde hubo cánticos alegría
lágrimas y emoción entre ellas las de la
secretaria vocera general del gobierno
Camila Vallejo quien fue una de las
impulsoras de esta norma en el 2017
cuando se encontraba en el parlamento
como diputada comunista estaba tan
emocionada que no Pudo realizar
declaraciones es uno de los éxitos del
gobierno del presidente Gabriel borich
fue una de sus promesas de campaña y se
espera que la ley se promulgue antes del
1 de Mayo durante su visita he estado a
Países Bajos el presidente de Francia
Manuel pronunció un discurso sobre el
futuro de la soberanía Europea el
mandatario francés a quien también fue
criticado por sectores sociales y
políticos neerlandeses por la reforma al
sistema pensional galo aprovechó para
hacer un llamado a los países europeos a
buscar una economía menos dependiente de
otras naciones
durante un discurso de 30 minutos en la
haya el presidente francés Emmanuel
macron llamó a buscar una mayor
soberanía europea durante el marco de su
visita oficial a Países Bajos una nación
con la cual ha mantenido diferencias
durante las últimas décadas
la pandemia y la guerra nos han empujado
a descubrir que debemos reducir nuestras
dependencias y queremos preservar la
identidad Europea de lo contrario poco a
poco seremos dependientes de todo
Después de sus polémicos comentarios
sobre Taiwán y la autonomía estratégica
europea Emanuel macron insiste esta vez
en la necesidad de la independencia
económica del bloque europeo
podemos poner en marcha una nueva
doctrina económica que nos permita
considerar la creación de empleo la
financiación de nuestro modelo social la
gestión del cambio climático y el hecho
de ser más soberanos y decidir por
nosotros mismos
el presidente de Francia llamó a
reforzar el peso de la Unión Europea
frente a China y Estados Unidos con el
desarrollo de políticas industriales
ambiciosas pero también con mayor
proteccionismo en sectores estratégicos
como la energía y la ciberseguridad
la Unión Europea se ha dotado por
primera vez de una herramienta para
bloquear o prohibir participaciones o
adquisiciones extranjeras en empresas
estratégicas
[Música]
es un cambio ideológico completo hasta
hace muy poco considerábamos que
estábamos abiertos Sin condiciones
macron también defiende la idea de un
comercio más justo al dejar de firmar
tratados de libre comercio con países
que no cumplan con el acuerdo de París
con el fin de reducir las emisiones de
CO2
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo a América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llega hernia Fernández Con toda
la información de nuestra red de
corresponsales en el mundo feliz noche
para todos
[Música]